so Gina and Rafal I understand that
you've been trying to make Tiger within
four years and it's 20 years
consistently fell apart is that right
well it fell apart
several times before Rafael ready and
then Rafael read it and we just it was a
melding of spirits and I committed to
him and he's been on point on that
trying you know I read it and I just
burst into tears it just there was
something so touching and moving that I
just couldn't get through it actually I
couldn't read it and you know it's rare
to find a script that just touches your
heart so much and that's well it was
really the essence of you know just
falling in love with this this movie in
this character and this this very sad
lonely you know
wonderful soulful character of this girl
case you know that's just lost in the
streets and she's like desperately
looking for love for a father figure it
just touches your heart and you know
that's how it all came about well can
you give us a sense of what you've done
to pitch the film before going to the
Kickstarter what were some of the
meetings like what were some of the ups
and downs of it what were you told I've
never really pitched it anywhere because
I wrote it on spec and and it's very
unlikely sell because you know you have
an unknown young girl and a very very
old man neither box-office draw and I
just wrote it cuz I wanted to
there was a Jewish settlement I was
working at Columbia one of my first jobs
really terrific time there in TV and I
would take breaks and just happen to be
behind it was like at the Paramount
sunset Gower studios and be right in
there behind there is this Jewish
cemetery and I didn't realize it it's
just a beautiful little park and I mean
I knew it was cemetary I didn't know it
was Jewish and I would walk through
there and I was just struck by these
monuments and I thought wow and
I just thought what loneliness but there
was like um there was a sweet lone
loneliness to it and then I thought of
all the people that look for each other
after the war and who found each other
and then I thought of you know how many
Runaways land here in LA looking for
something and they where are they gonna
sleep you know they sleep wherever they
can
and I just invented Casey because I read
somewhere I mean it was so stunning to
me that you know a bunch of people a
bunch of educated people in the middle
of the country denied the Holocaust ever
happened and I just was like that's just
not possible is that possible and I
couldn't get it out of my mind that that
educated book smart people professors
even believed that it was like you know
didn't it and so I thought yeah I've
seen a lot of kids you know like the
whole Doc Martin thing you know it's
like a skinhead thing and now it's
fashion but it's like how many of those
kids really know what the swastikas
stand for and the power of the symbol
and that's where it came from for me
interesting so you say you never
formally tried to pitch it really no I
mean I'd have you know my agents of
course would read it and at one time I
had an agent that was very supportive of
it in its tiny niche and it was almost
set up and then that director fell apart
and then it just was you know sitting
around for a long time and then you know
I felt did my very first movie you that
was awful play and I told we were like
you know hanging one day and he's I said
that I wrote something that probably
would never get made but I'll turn it
into a play and he read it and he
renewed my belief because I don't I'm
not I don't know how to get money and do
things like that to get it going you
know he's the director well well
actually you know I I pitched it maybe a
thousand times and
have written like thousands of letters
gone to hundreds of meetings and went
everywhere you know to Hollywood with it
and by himself
you know after fan when this special
jury awarded sentence like all the doors
opened and I was able to go and see
every president of every studio every
major executive a major producer and I
always would tell them you know this is
one of the films or do film actually I
want to do next and they would just give
me you know these all these huge films
that none of them actually I ended up
getting to direct and you know whatever
whenever I wanted to pitch this they it
just just I don't know it's just like
didn't happen you know and and I think
it's it's just one of those beautiful
scripts that just falls in between the
cracks you know it's not a huge film
that can attract stars it's it's not
like some kind of a you know blockbuster
material it's not something that and I'm
not a Steven Spielberg you know who can
just you know it's not funny
you know so um so it was always a
struggle you know and you know when
there were times when it was you know we
just said we're just gonna make it we're
just gonna make it with you know it's
just such a beautiful story it has to be
told the theme of it it's so powerful so
touching and it's a theme that applies
to the whole world at large
it's not just a Holocaust themed story
it's a story about everything that's
going on in our world today and our
world is now getting better it seems to
be getting worse and worse you know it's
getting more and more precarious you
know so I think this film in in a funny
way you know some script just sort of
date
they like the story dates it's like it
has been storied but this story becomes
more and more and more relevant in
contemporary each day you know and
that's why I just love it and it's just
about motion you know it's not based on
anything that's current you know a lot
of times you'll read a stripped you know
go oh that's so 70s you know or that's a
rabies or because it's and not done in
an ironic way like looking back but
having been written then and it's David
but if if there's a like the good movies
I think and I think I see them all like
I just saw Lawrence of Arabia over the
weekend and it's just so brilliant and
you go wow it's as it's as rich today is
then richer I mean you couldn't make
that today but it's just so brilliant
and those are the kind of things that
interest both of us that that have
emotional stability you know that it's
true it's emotion yeah it's just it's
it's that it just touches your heart and
that's you know each I've read this
maybe the script maybe 200 times and
each time I just you know well up and I
have to stop and that's the power of it
that is the power of it you know and you
know there's the timelessness of it and
everything the fashion changes you know
the character may she may listen to this
music or that music but ultimately the
story is a beautiful pure story and a
story that could take place right now in
Palestine or Afghanistan or Tibet you
know it's it's such a beautiful
universal story about old age news and
to people who are opposites who have
lost their families they have to come
together and it's about you know
creating a new family yes some people
are lucky and get born into a loving
family but not very many and it's a big
moment in the movie when he chooses her
and that's like a scene about choosing
because she's like why do you want me
you know you can't just choose your
family but I think Modern Life does that
you know because so many of our original
families don't work and you find the
components that are gonna make you the
best person you can be
that's I think what modern family is now
we're allowed to
you